star versus the forces of evil maybe one
of the best kids shows ever but it has a
ton of jokes that are definitely
inappropriate
check out these tin jokes that were
totally not meant for kids watch until
the end to find out which character set
she wanted to make some magic with her
crush now that's what we call forward
again we do need adult novels Mina
vivere is one crazy character she's got
some cool magical abilities but she is
totally weird she goes dumpster diving
and thinks living on earth is like being
in the wild but Mina is still a woman
and she has a very adult hobby in
Monster Bash Marko discovers her stash
of books and let's just say Mina is
definitely not reading young adult
novels she's reading a certain genre of
romance that is just for adults there's
a book called secret husband another one
is called a night to remember and we
have a feeling that night is memorable
for a very inappropriate reason there's
also 30 shades of magic that's
definitely a reference to a very mature
series of books and movies about the
color grey your mother
this next adult joke is from the very
first episode Marko isn't too pleased to
meat pony head at first he's jealous
but Marko isn't the best at insults or
is he when pony head and marcos start
playing a sword fighting game they
trash-talk each other you go in
oh yeah well your mother's a horse Pony
hat is all like duh of course pony has
mom is a horse or at least the head of a
horse but Marco definitely did not mean
a real horse he was calling Pony heads
mom a mean word that sounds a lot like a
horse come on Marco why did you have to
resort to your mom jokes not cool
royal bed mom girl is one creepy
character we meet her in the episode
King Ludo mime girl has a really
disturbing habit she likes to sneak into
King widows bed and sleep but it sure
seems like she was doing more than
sleeping and sleep in his royal bed she
was miming that we sleep in his royal
bed as one Reddit user said do you
typically bounce up and down with a
happy expression on your face when you
sleep nope
this makes mime girl even creepier
subtle Disney real subtle what parents
do mr. and mrs. Diaz love each other a
lot there aren't any cartoon couples
that are as affectionate as they are and
they have definitely found a way to keep
the romance alive but they really need
to work on boundaries and privacy and
storm the castle Marco's parents are on
the couch they are under some blankets
and they are making weird noises you
they told start we were just looking at
Rafael's old book of medical
illustrations that definitely did not
belong in a kid's show hot tub oh man
mr. and mrs. Diaz give us lots of
inappropriate moments let's look at the
time star took them on vacation that
whole episode was really dark and had
some deep messages about tourists
visiting other countries but the really
adult part was in the hot tub scene
Marco and star find Marco's parents
totally naked in the hot tub if that
isn't bad enough for a kids show it gets
worse mr. Diaz asks king butterfly if he
cares for a dip yep they asked star's
dad to join them in the hot tub where
they aren't wearing clothes how did that
joke make it into a Disney show the
flasher Diaz family vacation has so many
mature moments and this next one is just
gross
mr. and mrs. Diaz are enjoying all the
sights and taking lots of pictures of
course all they are seen are starving
people and orphans then a creepy guy
comes out of nowhere he opens a blanket
that was wrapped around him and says
that he has what they
need mr. and mrs. Diaz gasp at first and
start taking pictures this guy is
definitely supposed to be like a flasher
wearing a trench coat uh that's a crime
dude think that's inappropriate
keep watching for the most adult joke in
the show jelly bean hallucination
sometimes the adult jokes and star
versus the forces of evil are about
illicit substances this next joke is one
of those times and it's just really not
a good idea for a kid show star hits
buff frog with a jelly bean he stalks
slower like he's under the influence of
something substances that make you
hallucinate are seriously bad news but
that is definitely what they were
referencing in the scene tentacle arm
and monster are Marco gets hit with a
spell it turns one of his arms into a
giant tentacle Marco is upset at first
until he starts getting attention from
girls these girls are swooning over his
weird tentacle one even asks if the arm
can be her boyfriend we're pretty sure
that this is a really inappropriate joke
these girls don't just want to go to
dinner and a movie with Marcos arm they
have other very adult things on their
mind that is something we would never
expect to see on a cartoon for kids
stars bedroom in Blood Moon ball Tom
invites star to the demon's prom but
Marco isn't so sure of Toms motives he
worries about star and wants to go with
her and he's also a little jealous
while star is at the prom Marco goes
into star's bedroom he says he will have
his own blood moon ball and stars
bedroom where it's always fun huh what
does he mean by stars bedroom always
being fun we are pretty sure he is
implying that some very inappropriate
things happen in star's room but we are
talking about fighting monsters if you
know what we mean make some magic
this last joke is so obvious we were
shocked when we saw this one
everyone knows Jannah has a huge crush
on Marco but in Mew Bertie she takes her
flirting to the next level Marco is
looking for stars magic book to help her
with mewberty he finds it at school and
Janna is there Janna puts her arm around
him and says let's make some magic with
it Wow
we cannot believe that she said that any
adult can tell you that she is not
talking about magic spells she's talking
about something kids can't even
comprehend
it's just so obvious and they are just
young teens keep it together Jana what
is your favorite episode of star versus
the forces of evil let us know in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
if you love this magical show for more
videos like this one make sure to hit
that subscribe button thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]